Charlize how do you have a Premiere in
front of the dang on Coliseum in Rome I
know look at the light it's like a
cinematographer just lit it it's like
perfect it's like
go it's crazy
to celebrate with you did you bring your
babies I got some I got some fam here I
mean I feel like honestly Universal has
has become my family so in a weird way
Amir was really good friends and family
who I've been in the business with for
over 25 years so it's really nice I mean
last night we just went like who gets to
have a Premiere it's like Coliseum I was
like who the hell do you guys think you
are Universal like I mean but it's
amazing
I walked up today and I was like what
what is life what is life right now for
sure now I have a question because
yesterday we were talking and you were
really passionate about diversity and
inclusion and what this franchise has
meant for that and how important
representation is and I was just
wondering like has that always been so
ingrained in you or like now that you
are the mother of two black babies and
you see the world a little different is
is that has that heightened it for you
I think that I've always kind of like
lived in these two worlds where you know
I I was a white person who was a
minority growing up in a country and
then coming to this country and and
living in the reverse like I remember
being 16 years old and like walking down
the street I was like this is not what I
know and and so I think there is a
little bit of a hyper awareness when
you're watching shows and you're
realizing
yeah where are all the black people like
where are all the brown people
and so I think it's it's always been
there but I think now it's more of a
curated like I got two girls like I want
to make sure that when they watch
something I pointed out to them because
I don't want them to get complacent and
just thinking like it's this is fine I'm
like
where's the Asian character like I don't
understand why they're this is like this
should be told by an Asian character so
they they have a little bit of awareness
around that stuff that's a good Mama I
have to tell you now do they like this
franchise are they in the cars at all or
is it just whatever mama likes we like I
have one daughter that's definitely into
this stuff and then I have another
daughter that's not so much into this
stuff yeah yeah but uh they I've just
recently started like teaching them a
little bit how to drive and they're
super into that like super into that I
learned when I was nine on a tractor
that's why I was like it's time I gotta
like I gotta start and everyone's like
what are you doing I was like I was
eight or nine when I learned yeah yeah
so so we've been doing it let's go okay
I wanted to ask about Meadow because I
was talking to her earlier and she just
kind of blew me away how special it was
for you all to have her submit her dad's
legacy to this franchise in this way by
having her
yeah I mean listen this is like I feel
like this is such a private thing with
the core cast you know who kind of like
were there for one and knew him and
experienced the magic that he brought to
all of us I can say as a fan
as somebody who really likes these
movies and I really liked him in these
movies I feel like it's such a beautiful
kind of quota to
I think someone who was I didn't
personally know him but from what I hear
was just a true genuine Soul so
I can't think of a better way to honor
him than I mean I have kids I would want
to be honored that way so yeah
and and quickly have you have you been
able to talk to Anya Taylor Joy at all
about the Furious and what she's doing
and how are you excited about we have
not no we have not I met her years ago
and then I haven't I haven't really
uh I haven't been around her but
um you know like a function or anything
like that
but I can't think of a better actress
and I think she's gonna be totally okay
yeah without talking to me she's gonna
be absolutely fine
foreign